this episode is sponsored by google play
with the help of crash bandicoot on the
run
from the director of the justice
league's trailer
comes the film that rose from the ashes
to redeem that burnt orange tire fire
transforming it from a movie that was
two hours long and terrible
to a movie that's four hours long and
mediocre
proving once and for all if you want to
look great by comparison
just stand next to joss whedon the
snyder cut
for real this time
prepare for a film that wouldn't exist
without a powerful league uniting behind
it
joining the internet's most devoted fans
of targeted harassment
creatively bankrupt wb execs a parent
company who would happily piss on the
ashes of the last movie theater to sell
more broadband
the writer who sharted out rise of
skywalker and a director who was already
self-indulgent before he formatted a
film for imax
knowing it would be released on a
streaming service i think you just liked
how the bars added more darkness to
every scene right
that's free darkness right there baby
black suit up for an entirely different
take on the theatrical release
except for its plot setting main
characters and themes
where if you recall a gracie gi monster
covered in spikes
wants to destroy the world who's out to
impress his grey cgi monster boss
but this time follow in excruciating
detail
as this grey cgi monster reports his
progress
to his grey cgi monster bosses gray cgi
monster executive assistant
decide design i called to thee i
found one of the three the one that
woke and called let me make a plea to
him that i may come home
after i take the combined power of the
two mother boxes
i've been able to bring news before
[Music]
is carved into the surface of this very
world meanwhile
batman is still assembling a team of
heroes to protect the earth where they
will work together to bring back
superman
and quickly prove that there's no point
to a justice league
once you've brought back superman
honestly they have nothing to do besides
staying in a neat little line together
[Music]
good job team okay soups take it from
here
with two and a half casablancas worth of
runtime to fill
everyone's getting more character depth
like aquaman
who doesn't want to live under the sea
but doesn't want to be where the people
are either
because the surface world is full of
horny bjorks
the flash who's ditched the awkward
jokes dostoevsky
or awkwardly touching his wiener next to
iris west
batman who has so little to offer the
team they give him and alfred
a little airplane to work on as a treat
best minds away in aerospace couldn't
make it fly
and cyborg where the change from joss
whedon to zack snyder is most apparent
watch ray fisher shine as the emotional
heart of the story
and the heir to batman's mantle of
depression who's lost his body
lost his parents and might be the only
college football star
to risk losing his place on the team for
academic violations
that doesn't mean he can hack into our
system to change his friends grades
you know this dude plays for gotham you
and they just beat a big ten program
like wisconsin not only does he get a
pass for hacking grades there's a 90
chance bruce wayne just bought him an
escalade
prepare your anus for snyder's trademark
brand of muscular visual filmmaking
packed to the brim with honks allergic
to their own shirts
[Music]
here boo boo that woman where every
action scene
got immeasurably better thanks to new
additions
like amazon horse violence
atlantean bloodbending
the gods of olympus reminding darkseid
who's the daddy
extreme sesame seed close-ups
and heroes who take time to inspire the
next generation before their victims
brains have even finished dripping down
the walls can i be like you someday
you can be anything you want to be but
man at the risk of beating a dead
superman
this guy loves his slow
motion
i mean come on the flash's super speed
gets the same treatment as lois lane
putting down a cup of coffee
is her drink going back in time or she
just extra sad about her husband
so gather round for the epic culmination
of a mass movement
built around the sincere belief that it
wasn't enough for zack snyder to do
whatever he wanted for two box office
disappointments
it's not enough that grim superhero
storytelling is basically its own genre
now
no this film had to exist in its purest
form
or rather this film always existed in
its purest form
and the 70 million dollars warner spent
on it was for uh
snacks or something but now that it's
finally here
snyder's biggest fans can finally lay
down their arms and be satisfied that
their hero's journey got a proper ending
oh come on so wave as you pass by scenes
that were clearly setting up multiple
sequels
teasing fans with the ultimate fantasy
of watching dark side in superman take
the rest of earth to pound town
ensuring that every tweet article or
public statement about warner brothers
will get swarmed with a hashtag restore
the snyder verse something that will
never
ever happen until dc's annual firing of
the executives and the next ones make it
happen
bullying remains undefeated y'all wait
it's still not over
that was a natural place to stop uh
welcome
entirely new additions like martian
manhunter
whose appearance raises questions like
where the [ __ ] has martian manhunter
been
and how often does he hit the town
disguised as diane lane and jared leto's
joker
finally sharing a scene with ben
affleck's batman i mean they clearly
didn't film together but you can imagine
what it would be like if they finally
shared a scene
who's gonna give you a reach around it
would suck
okay this thing is way too long and i've
been holding in p since part four
can you just roll every time they say
mother box i'll be right back
[ __ ]
[Music]
motherbox mother boxes other boxes
motherbox
mother boxes ah that's better
all right time for starring
daddy wore bats i'm rich wonder woman
restorer of ancient art and antiquities
never mind it's not a phase mom this is
who i am now
every heisting needs an i.t guy debbie
drowner
i want to be left alone this is a bad
idea his father's dead because of us
quips over mr t put the water in first
so we don't scrawl the tea that's
probably enough tea
and then leave it to mash big city elegy
ah put the spikes back on put that
spikes back on
is this movie rushing or dragging it's
dragging maybe this guy should stop
working with robots
the boar is lava i'm made of rocks as
you can see
i don't let that intimidate you martha
manhunter
the living joke meera's accent
the first born of beloved queen atlanta
you are the firstborn son of queen
atlanta
and your mama's box is so smelly
steppenwolf can track it halfway across
the globe
you have been near a mother box the
scent is on you
oh justice league bigger longer and
uncut
working on an id sketch
where did they find that sketch artist
the leprechaun guy
this episode is sponsored by google play
download crash bandicoot on the run
and discover more on google play now hey
there fellow travelers
i'm trying my best mom i never actually
said this sentence
screen junkies now has a synthetic
approximation of my voice
made from previous recordings